It's a usual thing to note that there's a relationship between the class NP
and the cluster problems that are solvable in exponential time.
Any problems that's in NP is also going to be solvable in exponential time.
So the set of exponential time solvable problems includes NP.
Now that by includes I mean that it takes at most exponential time.
None of the problems in NP can be any harder than that,
say requiring double exponential time or factorial time or whatever happens will be,
they can all be solvable in exponential time.
So if the problem is in NP that means there's a bound on the size of the certificate needed.
Say it's polynomial n to the c for some constant that's specific to this problem,
where n is related to the size of the input
and there is also a bound on the running time of the verification algorithm like n to the k where
again is related to the size of the input and k is some constant that
can depend on the problem but it can't depend on the input.
Well, if we have those two things, we can actually create an algorithm
that can solve the problem for any input.
So what it needs to do is we can just run through all the certificates
that could possibly be relevant for the input x and for each one we run the verification algorithm,
and if the verification algorithm ever says--oh, yeah that's something that shows that x is true,
then we can return true as the solution for the problem and if we run through
all the possible certificates and none of them made the accepting, the verification algorithm return true
then we can return false, and the running time of this algorithm
is well the number of times we go to this loop is like 2 to the n to the c,
if we imagine the size of this certificate is written down in bits.
This is the number of different assignments of bits to certificates of this size.
So if we run through all possible into those, we know that we've checked everything
and then for each of those the running time is in the order of n to the k.
So the total running time is like n to the k,
which is a polynomial times 2 to the n to the c, which is exponential.
So the total running time is exponential. It's not worse than exponential. It's not great.
Unless we are talking about problems that are really tiny, this is going to be horrible,
but sometimes problems really are tiny and mostly I'm introducing this as a way of just connecting
these two concepts of the class NP and what it means to be able to find an exponential time.
It's nice to know that at least any problem that's in NP is solvable.
All right, we can write an algorithm that would run it.
It just that algorithm may take a very, very long time to complete.